alors on s'est fait de la mise en scène
est mis en scène les robins eric et
ramzy kadéos patrick bosso isabelle
lanthier et puis un jour sur le tournage
de la tour montparnasse infernale
christian fechner vous dit tu devrais
écrire ton film a déjà il commença à
travailler dans votre dans votre tête
mais fechner même pas l'idée que le
héros reste un gamin comme ça qu'ils
soient complètement lunaire vous voyez
chabat ensuite vous voyez claude berri
qui vous dit c'est formidable
malheureusement chez pathé ça se passe
pas aussi bien et vous rencontrer
laurent pétin et la lui il aime l'idée
il a envie de faire le film
il est très inquiet parce que bleach
être obligé d'abandonner mon rôle pour
pour un jamel debbouze pour un clovis
cornillac que j'adore alors que vous
citez mais c'est vrai que ça me faisait
mal au derrière de donner mon frère tu
vois c'est tout près de donner mon
personnage même à un acteur que j'adore
comme djamel ou cornillac parce que
parce que je me l'écrivait c'est ma vie
quoique j'ai mis de danger je
m'attendais à ce qu'on me propose et on
m'a pas proposé de paiement est
difficile parce que tout le monde a été
à comme un peu échaudé par l'échec
d'ordre on a fait quand même 1 million
800 mille spectateurs mais comme il est
marqué dans toutes les vitrines que
c'était de la merde et c'est sûr que ça
fait mal
ouais se retrouve un peu son travail
pour certains d'entre nous et ça m'a
permis d'écrire un bon film et ben voilà
vous êtes là ce soir la finale moi et je
ne reviens pas